le point le plus haut de paris ce n'est
ni la tour eiffel ni la butte montmartre
mais les jardins de belleville ils ont
ouvert en juillet dernier et déjà on
parle d'une extension 18 mille mètres
carrés de verdure en plus dans le 20e
arrondissement de paris patrick damien
de la rue de palikao à la rue piat au
coeur du 20e arrondissement
quinze mille mètres carrés de jardin en
escaliers sont ouverts au public depuis
jules hié colline artificielle créée en
1984 sont anciennes carrières de gypse
ce nouveau parc est un des plus hauts
sommets de paris avec ses terrasses de
fleurs son escalier tonnelle plongeant
jusqu'à la rue julien lacroix ses
nombreux jeux d'enfants les jardins de
belleville vont être élargis en
contrebas par le parc de palikao de
conception plus simplifié ce parc de 18
mille mètres carrés viendra s'intégrer
dans la cité voisine pour créer un
véritable village dans la ville les
travaux viennent de commencer et
l'ensemble devrait être terminée en
octobre prochain pour l'inauguration
officielle